Sì.
[Música]
Olá, pessoal. Nossa, que prazer que é
para mim táar aqui com vocês, né? Fico
muito contente de estarmos aqui falando
para um público tão grande e falando
coisas tão importantes que vai rolar
essa noite aqui com nessa live. Então,
para quem tem problema de memória, que
acha que tá cruzando aquela linha onde
começa a ter um uma diminuição da sua da
sua memória, da sua cognição, do seu
aprendizado, que não consegue tomar mais
decisões como tomava antes, não consegue
ter aquele pensamento ou ter um
brainfog, que é como se tivesse uma um
uma venda nos olhos, não consegue pensar
direito. Fico muito contente de você tá
acompanhando a gente, porque hoje a
gente vai falar sobre a importância de
rejuvenescer nosso cérebro com dicas
super importante, tanto pra memória como
também para Alzheimer. Então, a gente
inicia essa live falando da sua do desse
grande momento, né, que esses dois
grandes médicos me inspiraram a fazer o
programa do Recode, onde os dois têm
essa certificação também.
A gente vai conversar sobre isso. E
recode é reverse cognitive decline in
Alzheimer. Isso significa que já existem
trabalhos e estudos mostrando que é
possível sim você melhorar, você
diminuir a intensidade e até curar-se
desse desse desse grande mal que nós.
Mas o principal, eu acho que o ponto
aqui é a gente entender que existem
formas da gente prevenir isso. E para
isso eu tenho grande prazer de ter aqui
a Dra. Olana Castro e o Dr. Alan Dutra,
que fazem parte desse grupo, né? E a
gente vai conversar sobre isso hoje
também. Talvez tenhamos, eu não sei, eh,
ainda o Dr. Tipo Whtney ficou de estar
conosco aqui. Estamos no aguardo dele.
Se por acaso não der para ele participar
dessa vez, por qualquer motivo pessoal
que possa ter, contamos com ele numa
próxima eh numa próxima apresentação.
Queria então pedir primeiramente pra
Doutora Poliana Lies always first, né,
D? Então, certeza não conhece
integrativo e a gente vai est falando
sobre a importância do record para
restabelecer tanto a a saúde cerebral,
assim como rejuvenecê-la, para que a
gente possa ter maior clareza, falar de
memória e também falar de como tratar o
Alzheimer. Então, para isso, queria
muito apresentar para vocês a Dra. da
Poliana Castro, que já nos conhecemos há
há alguns anos, né, e temos tido
uma interação bem bacana para que isso
possa acontecer no Recode, a parte de
medicina, odontologia, nutrição. E eu
tenho aprendido muito com esse com essas
duas feras da saúde integrativa. Então,
Poliana, se você pudesse, por gentileza,
se apresentar e comentar conosco como
que você conheceu o programa Recode e
depois passar pro Alan e depois a gente
vai pro segundo assunto, né? O que que é
o recod?
Eh, então, eh, eu sou médica
neurologista.
Ah, inicialmente eh fiz a minha formação
tradicional e através da residência
médica e neurologia. Eh, depois eu fiz
mestrado em neurologia e neurociências
na UNIFESP, na Escola Policina,
eh, eh, fiz subespecialização
eh em doença de Parkinson e distúrbios
do movimento. Eh, e como eu sempre tive
eh uma predileção para estudar doenças
neurodegenerativas,
a minha tese de mestrado foi em
acometimento cognitivo ah na doença de
Parkinson, né? Então, eh, eu fui um elo
entre o distúbio do movimento e a
demência na no momento em que eu estava
estudando pro meu mestrado.
Eh, eh,
posteriormente a isso, eh, eu, hã,
comecei a a me aprofundar dentro da
medicina funcional, né? Eh, fiz
pós-graduação, eh,
em medicina funcional. eh e depois
prática ortomolecular e uma série de
outras eh de outras formações dentro da
da prática integrativa.
Eh, e fiz também a a formação, a
certificação internacional do método
Record.
Eh, então isso é um um pouco a respeito
da eh da minha formação, né? Eh, e aí,
eh, como eu conheci, eh, foi, eh,
justamente na época em que eu comecei a
estudar medicina funcional,
eh, dentro da pós-graduação mesmo, eh
que eu comecei a a, eh, a ouvir mais
sobre o que que havia eh dentro da eh
das práticas integrativas aplicadas à
neurologia, né? Então, foi nessa época
que eu ouvi falar eh sobre o protocolo
de code, né? E daí comecei a estudar eh
sobre o método naquela
época.
Muito bom. Muito obrigada, viu? E Alan,
e você como que você conheceu? Bom,
primeiro se você puder se apresentar e
também comentar pra gente como você
conhece.
Acho que pessoal, a maioria do pessoal
deve me conhecer, né? porque a gente tá
transmitindo principalmente nas minhas
eh mídias. Mas o meu nome é Dr. Alan
Dutra, eu sou formado há mais ou menos
28 anos. A minha formação original é é
cirurgia geral e urologia.
Aproximadamente uns 10 anos eu mudei
totalmente a minha prática para
trabalhar com medicina funcional
integrativa estilo de vida, por conta de
vários desafios pessoais que eu tive.
Primeiro com a minha saúde e com a saúde
da minha esposa. Minha esposa tinha uma
doença autoimune. Ela tinha eritema
nododoso, que era muito difícil tratar
pelas técnicas convencionais.
E também eu tinha uma enxaqueca de
repetição, eu tinha intestino irritável
e minha qualidade de vida tava muito
ruim,
porque eu trabalhava em vários
hospitais, vários serviços
e
de modo que esses desafios que eu tive
na minha vida pessoal, eles foram
determinantes para que eu buscasse
alternativas. Aí eu comecei a estudar
medicina automolecular e depois que
nasceu meu filho, ele foi diagnosticado
com Teia, eu ainda aumentei mais ainda
esses estudos.
e fiz várias formações na medicina
funcional integrativa, fiz a pós do Albt
Einstein, fiz a pós-graduação do Lai
Ribeiro. Depois eu fui fazer a formação
lá nos Estados Unidos do
ANM, né, que é um instituto de medicina
funcional bem conhecido lá nos Estados
Unidos. E quando eu tava fazendo a pós
do Lai Ribeiro, eu acabei conhecendo o
livro do Recode. Então, eu tinha acabado
de lançar o livro do Recode em inglês. E
eu conheci esse livro quase que por
acaso. Eu comecei a estudar em inglês
esse livro e eu fiquei fascinado porque
era um resumo de tudo que eu tava
estudando de medicina funcional. É como
se fosse um resumão. Eu fiquei tão
empolgado que comecei a fazer vídeos a
respeito. Então acho que eu devo ter
sido a primeira pessoa no Brasil que fez
vídeo sobre o protocolo BR Code. E mais
interessante, eu tinha vários pacientes
que frequentava os Estados Unidos e um
deles quando voltou de lá falou: "Olha,
tá tendo o curso Dr. Dale Braden". Ou
seja, foi um paciente meu que me
informou, sabia que eu tinha interesse
por esse assunto, que eu tinha lido o
livro, que eu aplicava já os
conhecimentos do livro do o fim do
Alzheimer, né, o nome do livro traduzido
pro português.
E eu acabei procurando lá a equipe do
Dr. Bradsen e
me inscrevi então no programa do Recode,
fiz o curso, eu acho que eu fui o
segundo da América Latina a fazer, o
primeiro do Brasil e eu fiz o Recode
1.0, que era em parceria com IFM, com
Institute for Functional Medicine, e
depois eu fiz o Recode 2.0.
Foi essa a minha história com Bode. E
assim, para as pessoas entenderem,
algumas pessoas ficam muito curiosas em
saber porque que um urologista tá
mexendo com doença neurodenativa.
Primeiro que eu tenho um interesse
pessoal sobre esse tema. Eu tenho
familiares com a doença, tenho eh quatro
pessoas na família com a doença.
E também a questão que eu descobri que a
abordagem do recode era totalmente em
cima de uma medicina funcional, uma
medicina de corpo todo, não era algo
relacionado a uma especialidade, apesar
de ser uma uma doença neurológica, o
protocolo recode é um protocolo de de
medicina funcional. Então, de maneira
alguma a gente tenta ou o ou tem a
intenção de substituir um especialista,
mas é porque realmente os especialistas
hoje em dia tem uma visão muito
fragmentada da medicina, tem uma visão
muito compartimentalizada. Então a gente
tem que voltar, dar um passo atrás e
estudar a medicina como um todo, a
interligação entre órgãos e sistemas.
Isso, o recode, eh, foi assim que ele
começou, porque o Dr. Dale Bradsen, ele
é casado com uma médica de medicina
funcional lá nos Estados Unidos. Quando
ele estudava o modelo do Alzheimer no
rato e na mosca, ele tava fazendo como
todo mundo tava fazendo na época. ee
tava buscando uma molécula única que
tinha que ser modificada através de
algum tipo de medicamento para que
houvesse, né, a reversão da doença ou
tratamento adequado à doença. Então ele
descobriu a duras penas, né, e também
pela influência da esposa dele, que a
doença era multifatorial. E aí que ele
desenvolveu o protocolo para atacar 36
mecanismos moleculares diferentes para
eh ele foi o primeiro a ter um resultado
consistente na reversão do défic
cognitivo
e no tratamento da doença. E saiu estudo
Evanteia, talvez o Chip Whtney, se ele
puder se juntar a nós, ele pode comentar
sobre isso também. Mas recentemente saiu
o estudo Evante, que foi o primeiro
randomiz control trial, primeiro estudo
randomizado duplo cegoo, mostrando que
esse protocolo é sete vezes melhor que o
Leenbi, que é o Lecanumab, que é uma
droga aí super badalada, que acabou de
ser lançada no Brasil, foi largamente
eh divulgado na imprensa sobre essa
droga.
Então o protocolo realmente ele é bem
trabalhoso, ele é bem completo, complexo
até, mas ele vale muito a pena porque
ele é a única ferramenta que nós temos
hoje em dia que de fato altera a
evolução da doença.
Então essa é minha história com
tá tendo eco aí algum lugar.
O Dr. Chip Whitney tá tentando entrar,
ele tá aqui comigo no telefone.
Ah, e está tentando entrar. Eu peço, dou
alguma orientação para ele. Alan,
é usar o link, tipo assim, é o mesmo
link, eh, não tem dificuldade.
Muito bem, então vamos tocando aqui, né?
Enquanto
o Rodrigo tá tentando acertar lá com o
tipy, eu queria perguntar para você,
Dra. Poliana, eh, como é que tem sido a
sua experiência com protocolo recode?
E também uma coisa que eu tenho
curiosidade, eu sei que você trabalha
com equipamento,
eh, que
também o Dr. Fábio Bechell também
trabalha. Eu queria que você falasse
como é que tem sido os seus resultados a
associando o protocolo com o
equipamento.
Eh,
oi, pessoal. É, desculpa só eh o Dr.
Tipo WN pediu para se desculpar que ele
não tá conseguindo conectar e que ele
vai ter em breve paciente para atender
agora, mas a gente ficou depois de
marcar uma outra com ele, tá bom?
OK.
Então vamos tocar em português mesmo,
tá bom?
Tá bem.
Pode falar, por favor.
Eh, então a minha experiência com
Protocolo Recode, eh, sendo uma
neurologista que vende uma formação
tradicional, né? Eh, eh, é comum, é um
presente você poder, eh, ah, passar a
utilizar um método que seja eh eh que
agregue tanto em comparação eh ao que eh
ao que eu via eh dentro da prática
tradicional, né? Então,
eh,
para mim não tem nem não tem nem
comparação o que que o que eu, eh, ou
que observava de evolução, como que era
a evolução do paciente, observar a
evolução do paciente eh do do declínio
progressivo que o paciente tem eh pela
própria evolução natural da doença, eh,
e mesmo quando é introduzido o
tratamento farmacológico.
Eh, e a partir do momento em que eu
comecei a utilizar
eh a medicina funcional e e
principalmente os conceitos do protocolo
recode, que embora seja um programa
extenso, trabalhoso, que exige muito do
paciente, da família, eh existe muita,
exige muita eh modificação de estilo de
vida, exige muita, eh, modificação da
dinâmica familiar, porque não é um
tratamento de é de um único braço. A
gente precisa de vários braços, né, de
todo mundo arregaçar as mangas para eh
para promover tudo que precisa, pro
paciente conseguir fazer eh o tratamento
dele da melhor forma possível e dentro
daquilo que ele conseguir eh aplicar de
tudo que é orientado dentro do
tratamento,
né? Então, eh, para mim, é, eh, é assim,
mudou a minha prática clínica, a, a
abordagem da medicina funcional mudou a
minha prática clínica para melhor, tanto
no tratamento das doenças
neurodegenerativas,
quanto no tratamento eh dos das doenças
neurológicas da infância, como autismo e
TDH, porque eu também tenho eu tenho
dois filhos com autismo. eh foram eles
que me levaram a eh eh a procurar novas
abordagens, né? Eh e eles que me
ensinaram que havia assim mais o que a
gente pudesse estudar e mais o que a
gente pudesse fazer eh dentro de eh para
poder agregar dentro da dos tratamentos
em neurologia, né? Eh,
então, ah, para mim foi muito
transformador, eh, poder, eh, eh,
conhecer a as práticas práticas
integrativas que eu ainda continuo
estudando, eh, o que mais, né, a gente
pode fazer eh para tornar o mais
positiva possível eh eh a evolução do
paciente, eh, para máximo auxiliar em
relação a como que a gente pode auxiliar
na no melhor prognóstico em relação à
autonomia, em relação à melhora da
qualidade de vida do paciente, já que a
neurologia tradicional ela é conhecida,
como dizia um um grande professor da
neurologia da UNIFESPE, né? A neurologia
é conhecida como uma ciência de
brilhantes diagnósticos e pobres
resultados dentro do meio tradicional. E
aí, como neurologista, a gente acaba eh
muitas das vezes, né, se frustrando por
eh em muitas situações a gente eh dentro
os tratamentos que a gente conhece da do
do meio tradicional, eh, daquilo que
esteja reconhe reconhecido dentro das
melhores práticas e dentro da medicina
baseada em evidências e daquilo que é
recomendado dentro dos guidelines
internacionais, eh a gente acabar muit
das vezes eh eh vendo que acaba
assistindo né, o declínio do paciente eh
de forma assim inexorável,
eh, principalmente dentro das condições
neurodegenerativas,
né? Eh, então, a o protocolo recode e a
abordagem integrativa da neurologia como
um todo eh me auxiliaram a eh a ver as
coisas de uma outra forma, de uma forma
mais positiva e conseguir enxergar muito
mais resultados nos tratamentos
eh com impacto muito mais positivo eh na
qualidade de vida e na autonomia eh dos
pacientes do que quando usava apenas os
tratamentos tradicionais, né? Eh, e em
relação à terapia de neuromodulação que
eu utilizo, que atua na epigenética e
que utiliza um
é o React, né? Você fala do Reac, eu
queria saber sua experiência com React,
que é é o nome da da tecnologia, né?
É.
Eh, então, eh, o que que acontece? por
mais que haja eh haja estudos eh sobre
eh a a terapia com essa tecnologia para
pessoas com doença de Alzheimer, eh a é
um é um pouco é é muito menos trabalhoso
do que o protocoling. O protocol code é
bastante amplo, né? Muito mais
minucioso, muito mais estudado, né? Mas
o que eu observo eh na minha prática
clínica eh é que eles parecem ter um
efeito sinérgico, né? Eh, tendo em vista
que os pacientes que, eh, conseguem
fazer ambos os tratamentos eh acabam
somando efeito, acabam tendo efeitos eh
soma de efeitos positivos, né, na na
evolução clínica deles, né? Eh, é isso
que eu que eu observo na minha prática
clínica.
Muito bom. Eu eu queria também só
comentar aqui com o pessoal que eu
acabei não tendo oportunidade como que
eu conheci o Record. Primeiro conheci o
Record através do Alan e da Poliana, né,
que já tinham me falado. E quando eu fui
convidado para dar uma aula lá na
International Academy of Medicine
Toxicology,
quando o pessoal soube que eu ia dar
essa aula, o o tipo Wsney entrou em
contato comigo e falou: "Olha, será que
você poderia tá falando um pouquinho
sobre o ECOD, né?" Na na aula eu fiz um
trabalho para mostrar um trabalho
integrativo para mostrar como que os
procedimentos odontológicos auxiliavam
no rejucimento cerebral e auxiliavam na
microculação, na micronutrição, na
oxigenação e principalmente na limpeza
cerebral, possibilitando tirar aquela
célula de uma possível homotoxicose.
Aí, eh,
pediu para falar um pouquinho. Eu
naquela época eu já tava fazendo, já
tinha me inscrito, né? Porque vocês já
tinham falado tão bem nesse programa que
tinham tido resultados tão bons. Eu
falei: "Bom, então vou aproveitar e aí
tive a oportunidade de também mostrar um
uns eh uns slides que eles gentilmente
me cederam. E o que mais me chamou
atenção, que é o primeiro programa
multidisciplinar
com uma visão integrativa. Então é
importante a gente entender que precisa
ter o médico, precisa ter o dentista,
precisa ter o nutricionista, precisa ter
o fisioterapeuta ou personal, precisa
ter, se necessário, dependendo do nível,
o health coach, né, para tá auxiliando a
pessoa a se organizar, precisa ter ah
dependendo do caso, a a enfermeira para
tá ali, né, possibilitando todo o
tratamento.
a parte emocional, a parte de gerenciar
o estress. Então, muitas vezes a gente
precisa da parte emocional para est
cuidando disso, né? E aí você tem um
monte de coisas, inclusive fazer
exercício na esteira com oxigênio.
Alguém tem experiência dessa parte do
desse protocolo que você utiliza o andar
com a máscara de oxigênio? Alguém tem
experiência?
Eu tive alguns pacientes que fizeram
dessa maneira. Rodrigo, alguém tá com eh
tem que baixar um pouco o volume do
alofalante porque tá dando do eco. Tem
muita gente reclamando aqui no no
YouTube, não sei quem, se é o Rodrigo ou
se é Poliano, mas enfim.
Eh, sobre essa sua pergunta, eu tive
alguns pacientes que fizeram, tá? A
gente quando fez a pós do L Ribeiro, a
gente ficou sabendo que existia esse
protocolo de utilizar o oxigênio com
exercício e também com alguns
ultracêuticos associados. E eu fiquei
surpreso de ver que também no protocolo,
né, durante a formação, eles mencionaram
sobre isso, né, que
o protocolo aqui no Brasil tem é
conhecido por outro nome. Me fugiu o
nome agora, talvez a Polana se lembre,
mas daqui a pouco eu acho que volta na
minha mente. Mas enfim, tive alguns
pacientes, uns dois ou três que fizeram
e o resultado foi bem interessante,
Rodrigo, tá? tanto o uso de oxigênio
hiperbárico,
é uma pena que câmera hiperbárica é uma
coisa que ainda não é tão acessível. Eu
até pensei em instalar uma câmera na
clínica. O problema é que se você quiser
que o convênio pague, tem poucas
aplicações clínicas que eles pagam.
Então, e aí ia ficar um investimento um
pouco alto de montar a câmara e sem
saber direito como é que ia ser, quantos
pacientes iam iam aderir. Mas tanto a o
oxigoterapia hiperbárica quanto o a o
exercício com oxigênio, eles são
comprovadamente muito eficazes para
ajudar a resolver um dos problemas, né,
um dos tipos da doença de Alzheimer, que
é o tipo circulatório. Então eles
realmente ajudam bastante e obviamente
sozinhos não vão ter uma ação super
eficaz porque o programa, uma coisa que
eu aprendi com o programa é que os
pacientes têm pelo menos três tipos,
três subtipos de Alzheimer associados e
a maioria tem três, alguns têm quatro.
Então, mesmo que você melhora a
microcirculação e oxigenação, ainda vai
ser necessário cuidar da parte do
metabolismo glicolítico, né, da do
chamado diabetes tipo 3. Vai ser
necessário diminuir a inflamação, em
muitos casos vai ser necessário entrar
com fatores tróficos no cérebro. Então é
muito interessante. E outra coisa que
tenho visto também que funciona, que é
bem legal, é a fotobiomodulação,
né, que tem sido bem aí divulgado
recentemente, muitos trabalhos novos
falando da eficácia, tanto para
depressão, para doenças
neurodegenerativas, para várias doenças
neurológicas.
É outra terapia também de suporte muito
interessante. A eletroneiro e a
estimulação magnética também são
interessantes. Eu fiz a pergunta para
Opoliana porque o REAC é uma tecnologia
interessante, mas que até o momento eu
não vi os americanos comentarem sobre o
REAC, né? E como a Poliana
já tem uma experiência já alguns anos e
aplicando o Reac e eu não trabalho ainda
com essa tecnologia e poderia ser até
uma coisa bem interessante para
adicionar ao protocolo, né? E ela falou
muito bem, o protocolo é muito complexo,
infelizmente, no sentido de quê? de que
você tem que mexer muitas peças ao mesmo
tempo. Mudança profunda na dieta que os
pacientes têm muita dificuldade de
seguir, mas é fundamental sem essa
mudança dietética não se tem resultados.
Recentemente fiz uma live com uma
nutricionista que é uma das maiores aí
especialistas em dieta
eh cetogênica e ela mora em Portugal e a
gente percebe que até entre os
nutricionistas tem muita resistência com
a dieta e pouca formação e informação.
Então, até para você conseguir um nutre
que tenha bastante intimidade com a
dieta cetogênica no Brasil é um pouco
difícil, porque a formação e acadêmica
normal, eles não falam quase nada disso
e tem que ser uma coisa na pós-graduação
e pouca gente tem essa formação nessa
área. Então, a dieta é um grande desafio
para muitas pessoas também. O jejum é um
grande desafio que também é é uma peça
muito importante, especialmente
potadores de apo cópia ou duas cópias do
APE4. Você tem que fazer, se tiver uma
cópia, tem que fazer 14 horas ou duas
cópias, 16 horas de jejum.
A questão também do exercício físico,
muitos idosos chegam até mim já um
comprometimento físico que não consegue
mais fazer atividade física da maneira
adequada.
Isso é também um desafio para vários
pacientes. Tem muitos que chegam já com
déficit cognitivo acentuado, amoderado,
já não conseguem fazer também o estímulo
cerebral da melhor forma possível, fazer
exercícios mentais cerebrais.
H, as pessoas de modo geral tm uma
dificuldade muito grande em fazer
meditação ou técnicas de relaxamento.
Acho que o brasileiro deve ser o povo
mais estressado do mundo. Eu já vi um
estudo falando sobre isso, que o
brasileiro era um dos povos mais
estressados do mundo pela instabilidade
econômica do nosso país, né? Toda hora
aparece uma novidade, não é boa
geralmente, né? Então as pessoas ficam
sempre na ponta dos pés esperando o
próximo golpe. Então isso é uma coisa
que atrapalha muito as pessoas
aprenderem técnicas de meditação, de
relaxamento.
E ah o distúrbios de sono também é uma
coisa impressionante. Eu acho que 70% do
meus pacientes tem um disturbo de sono e
uns 40% deve ter a pneia obstrutiva do
sono. Então é muita coisa para mexer ao
mesmo tempo. E as pessoas quando chegam
no consór médico, muitas vezes elas não
estão habituadas com essa visão
holística. Elas estão acostumadas a ir
ao médico pegar uma receitinha, ir para
casa e tocar a vida como sempre foi. E a
gente tem que fazer esse papel de
praticamente virar um professor. E eu
tenho muito material nas minhas mídias
para ensinar isso. E a gente dá um monte
de coisa escrita, livros que eu mandei
traduzir pro português, paguei eh
tradutora para traduzir o livro e vídeos
e mais vídeos. Mas mesmo assim, eh, às
vezes é complicado você fazer uma
educação sistematizada na família toda,
porque quando vem um desses idosos,
geralmente ele tem três ou quatro
filhos, que eles são de outras gerações
e boa parte deles tem três ou quatro
filhos. Aí tem um filho que concorda,
tem um filho que discorda, o outro não
tá nem sabendo e fica aquela confusão.
Tem vários idosos, inclusive que até vi
a experiência da Poliana sobre isso, tem
vários idosos que às vezes ficam fazendo
temporadas, fica morando um tempo na
casa de de um filho, outro outra
temporada na casa de outro filho. E aí
um filho concorda, outro discorda. E é
outra coisa, coordenar esse trabalho de
família é um grande desafio também.
Seu microfone está fechado, Rodrigo.
Então, eu não sei. Eu acho que melhorou
a a o áudio,
ô Alan, porque eu acho que talvez possa
ser o microfone da Poliana,
não é? Tá tendo algum vazamento de áudio
de algum altofalante aí? Eh, não sei de
qual, de qual que é. o
o seu áudio dá para escutar, tá tudo
bem? Eh, eh, mas das próximas vezes
talvez a gente conseguir um microfone
melhor, mas tá dando para te entender.
Tá bom. Então, queria saber a sua
opinião, as dificuldades que você tem
encontrado
no
essas que o Alan começou a a comentar e
depois eu queria falar sobre a APNE e o
Vancou, né, que a gente tem tratado de
uma forma mais simples,
mas conta pra gente, por favor.
Bom, em relação às dificuldades
encontradas, eh, dentro do que eu
observo na na minha prática clínica, eh
concordo com Alan quando ele comenta
sobre eh a questão de de divergências eh
entre membros da família, porque afinal
de contas o paciente idoso eh que venha
para tratamento para um tratamento novo,
eh para um tratamento que infelizmente
ainda é pouco difundido, eh um
tratamento ainda ainda que ainda não se
ouve falar em congressos médicos
tradicionais,
né? É um tratamento que, basicamente, o
paciente quando descobre sobre a
existência eh do tratamento a partir a
partir da de uma busca da família, eh
geralmente um membro da família é aquela
pessoa que tá buscando o que mais a
gente pode fazer, existem novos
tratamentos e essa pessoa que geralmente
eh busca conversar com os demais filhos,
com demais membros da família, eh para
verificar se todos concordam de tentar
um novo tratamento, né? Eh, e o paciente
que muit das vezes eh, ah, muit das
vezes não tem nem a percepção adequada
do próprio adoecimento, porque existe
uma condição dentro do do adoecimento na
doença de Alzheimer muito frequente, que
é a nozognosia, que é a alteração da
capacidade da percepção do próprio
déficit neurológico. Então, muitas vezes
o paciente não não tem o alerta devido
em relação ao que tá acontecendo com
ele. família leva o paciente paraa
consulta e o paciente muitas vezes fala
assim: "Nossa, eu tô aqui porque a
família tá me trazendo, mas eu tô
ótimo". Eles dizem que a memória tá
ruim, mas a minha memória para mim tá
ótima. Eu tô aqui só porque eles me
trouxeram, né? Eh, e aí, eh, muitas
vezes pode ter alguém da família que tá
ali super dedicado de quero fazer o novo
tratamento, eh, e super engajado. E muit
das vezes outros membros da família eh
falam assim: "Ah, mas esse tratamento é
novo". Mas quando eu conversei com outro
médico neurologista, ele não me falou
sobre, então, será que é mesmo eh útil a
gente tentar esse novo tratamento? E aí
quando você faz as orientações eh eh
iniciais a respeito tratamento, né,
quando o paciente precisa começar a
modificar hábitos de vida, isso mexe com
a dinâmica da família, né? Eh, nessa
hora que
eh a eh a eh eh começa frequentemente
começa a surgir algum tipo de de
dificuldade ali eh no dia a dia e aí é
necessária a colaboração da família para
que haja, por exemplo, mudança de
hábitos alimentares, né? Eh,
e aí sem eh a colaboração da família
fica difícil de o pacienteir conseguir
atingir os alvos que ele precisa, eh,
dentro de cada parte do tratamento, né?
Então, ah, mas aí se a gente precisa
outras questões em relação à mudança de
hábitos de vida, se a gente precisa eh
atividade de implementar atividade
física, eh aí precisa de alguém para
levar o paciente para isso, quanto que
você pode contar com as demais
familiares para que isso se faça, né?
Eh, ah, se a gente precisa fazer
estimulação cognitiva e se o paciente tá
numa condição em que ele ainda não
consegue, em que ele não, por exemplo,
não dê conta de fazer sozinho e precisa
de algum suporte para fazer isso, né? O
quanto que a família consegue ajudá-lo
eh em relação a isso, né? né? Então,
precisa ter alguém disponível para isso.
Então, é relativamente é relativamente
frequente de eh haver um membro da
família
ou dois ou dois membros da família
eh que sejam aquelas pessoas que estão
mais engajadas e que se unem para tentar
auxiliar o paciente a implementar a as
orientações do tratamento.
Eh, e
a muit das vezes outros outros membros
acabam muitas das vezes não se
envolvendo muito, né? Então isso de fato
eh frequentemente funciona, acontece
como um obstáculo, né, ao tratamento.
Eh, e também assim
eh eu sempre falo que assim, quando você
tem eh um filho que você precisa levar
para tratar, quem é que vai determinar o
que vai ser feito tratamento para aquele
filho?
são os pais. E aí são só duas pessoas
para concordar ou discordar. Quando você
tá levando o seu pai e a sua mãe para
ser tratado, em geral, vai depender de
quantos filhos eh tão envolvidos ali na
tomada de decisão para saber se vai dar
certo ou se não vai aquilo que você
precisa, né? Então, frequentemente o
tratamento eh acaba eh ficando mais a
cargo de um ou dois membros da família,
que sejam aquelas pessoas que tão ali,
topam arregaçar as mangas para provere.
Eh, e muitas vezes outros membros da
família acabam não se envolvendo muito,
né? Então, tem a questão de quem
contribui, quem colabora no dia a dia
para que as coisas sejam implementadas,
para que as orientações sejam
implementadas. Eh, dois, quem concorda
ou quem discorda, né? Porque às vezes eh
o tratamento não consegue nem ser
iniciado se eh a maior parte da família
não concordar, né? E aí eh um dos
filhos, por exemplo, eu falo assim: "Ó,
doutora, me sinto como um mandorinha que
não faz verão. Então, se eu não consigo
ter ajuda dos meus eh dos meus irmãos
para prover isso pro meu pai ou paraa
minha mãe, aí na minha realidade atual,
nesse momento, eu não consigo
implementar um tratamento. Isso pode
acontecer. E o terceiro ponto é fator
financeiro, porque eh a o tratamento
custa, todo tratamento custa, né? Eh e o
recode custa porque ele muda um monte de
coisa na vida do paciente. Você gasta
com médico, você gasta com
suplementação, você gasta com dieta,
você gasta com modificação de apito,
você gasta com dentista, você gasta com
um monte de coisa, né? E aí, eh, nessa
hora que a gente vai, eh, conseguir ver
o que, o que que a família consegue se
mobilizar para, para fazer, porque às
vezes, eh, ah, uma filha traz a mãe para
tratar e fala assim: "Ó, doutora, eh, eu
queria muito fazer o tratamento, mas
acontece que sozinho eu não consigo eh
não estou conseguindo bancar todos os
custos do adoecimento, porque eu tenho
que cuidar das despesas financeiras da
dos meus filhos, eh, da minha casa e da
minha mãe, eu preciso dividir com os
meus irmãos." E aí, eh, não, não tô
conseguindo essa essa parceria, essa
divisão, então não tô conseguindo
implementar tudo que precisa, né? Então,
essas são diversidades frequentemente
encontradas, né? Eh,
é, você falou algumas coisas aí que me
identifiquei bastante, né,
a respeito
dessas situações de família mesmo que
você acaba de escrever. Uma coisa que eu
aprendi fazendo o protocolo Recode, que
me chama muito atenção, é que o esforço
para uma pessoa mudar o estilo de vida
quando parte dela, quando ela tem
incognição suficiente ainda para
promover a mudança, é um esforço
infinitamente menor do que quando você
depende de um terceiro. É uma coisa
desproporcional. Então, por exemplo, se
eu, Alan, resolvo mudar meu estilo de
vida, mudar alimentação, atividade
física,
começar a empreender hábitos que eu não
fazia antes, para mim é difícil, mas é
ainda muito mais fácil que quando
depende de um filho ou filha
eh aplicar isso em mim. Então isso é uma
das coisas que mais me chamou atenção
aplicando o protocolo recodo,
esse fenômeno que você falou que o
próprio paciente não percebe a queda
dele, eu vejo bastante na prática
clínica também. É uma coisa bem
frequente isso daí. E isso é uma coisa
que atrapalha muito o tratamento também,
porque a família tem que empreender um
esforço muito grande para poder
convencer o próprio doente a tomar as
medidas que tem que tomar, né? Então, é,
isso gera um desgaste emocional às vezes
muito grande, dependendo do caso.
Eu eu queria só só colocar que dentro de
todas essas dificuldades e eu agradeço
demais vocês. Eu acho que é o meu
microfone, né, que tá com
Olha, alguém falou que eu era culpado,
Rodrigo, eu até conectei o um fone com
fio no próprio microfone,
mas não mudou não. Eh, tá, tá, tá, tá.
continuar com eco.
Não, mas o volume
ol, feche o seu, por gentileza, só pra
gente ver.
Vamos ver então. Mas eu eu queria
primeiramente agradecer essa experiência
de que vocês têm colocado, né? Eh, e
queria comentar que dentro desse
protocolo foi o que inspirou a gente
montar o Record, o a o CIS, né, o
simpósio internacional de saúde
integrativa, que vai acontecer agora dia
13. 14 e 15 de março, que vamos ter a
participação especial do Dr. Whitney,
que é professor também do programa do
desse desse
programa Recode,
eh, desenvolvido pelo Dr. Dale Britz e
que temos Dra. Alan, Dra. Poliana, né,
que fazem parte, assim como eu também, e
que a gente vai ter toda essa forma,
então, desde a vai ter professores
nutricionistas para falar sobre a
importância, por exemplo, do intestino,
a importância do
da limpeza do fígado, a mitilação,
processo de desintoxicação de metais
tóxicos, a desparasitação,
a dieta cetogênica, o jejum,
intermitente, a parte emocional, a parte
odontológica. Vamos ter a Dra. Regina
Mcash falando sobre a importância da
respiração, apneia, ronco, né? convidei,
não tive ainda o OK, mas o
tem um dentista, o Dr. John, que teve
aqui o a a a o CIS passado, que ele fala
também sobre a Pneia Ronco, falou muito
bem, convidei ele. Vamos ter o Jerry
curatola falando sobre o microbioma
bucal e também eh trazendo a saúde
cerebral, que é o lá de Nova York, que
para mim é um dos maiores dentistas
biológicos do mundo. O Di tem uma série
de estudos organizados e vai falar sobre
o microbioma.
A gente vai ter também ah
nutricionistas, né, falando de toda essa
importância.
Vamos ter falando sobre cavitação óssea,
porque a gente vê estudos do Leer
informando que o CCL5, que é aquele
soldado que acaba crescendo dentro
daquele osso que não cicatrizou de forma
correta, ele vai iniciar o processo e
tem milhares de artigos relacionando,
são mais de 4.000 artigos relacionando o
CCL5 por causa da capavitação óssea,
juntamente com o problema de Alzheimer.
Vamos também est falando sobre a
importância do mercúrio, que também tá
relacionado ao Alzheimer e doenças
autoimunes, neurodegenerativas,
degenerativas.
Vamos ter a
também falando sobre a parte de medicina
regenerativa. Então, tanto a Dra. Ana
Moreira de Portugal, como também que vai
est contribuindo, que foi a presidente
do congresso lá em Portugal, vai est
participando da sua experiência e eu
tive a oportunidade de conversar com ela
no congresso mundial que teve no Rio de
Janeiro e eu fiquei impressionado com a
experiência que ela tem, com esses
resultados que ela tem tido. Então, mais
uma internacional aí pra gente. O o
Felipe Caquete vai também falar sobre
medicina regenerativa. Então a gente vê
que depois que faz todo o processo, não
deu resultado, ainda tem ainda a opção
de se fazer as células tronco. E isso a
gente também vai tá mostrando. Sem
contar que vai ter uma feira enorme eh
aberta ao público, exatamente para verem
as tecnologias,
as opções que tem de tratamento, os
produtos que tem. Então, 13, 14, 15 de
março, agora 2026. Se você tiver mais
interesse, depois busca aqui. Acredito
que a gente possa deixar o link, né,
Dra. Alan, para que o pessoal possa
entrar e conhecer mais. Dra. Alan vai
estar lá conosco, Dra. Paulina vai estar
conosco, Dra. Jea Quental,
Dra. Elizete Cfer. Bom, enfim, são 40
grandes profissionais da área de saúde.
Vamos ter também um assunto novo, porque
a gente entende que é muito importante
controlar comida, né? Mas também é muito
importante a gente controlar a água, a
qualidade da água. Então, para isso,
pedi para um grande amigo meu,
Claudinei,
que ele pudesse est explicando pra gente
sobre a importância da água e como que a
tecnologia que ele desenvolveu pode
estar ajudando isso. A gente vai ter o
professor Irineu também.
Bom, são 40 amigos que vão estar conosco
e é um evento que vocês precisam
participar. Peço ajuda na divulgação
dessa live para quem é para aquelas
pessoas que você acha que possa estar
sendo beneficiado. E queria também pedir
eh para vocês agora pudessem estar
falando durante 3 minutos cada um, dando
um spoiler do que cada um vai falar no
durante esse evento. Pode ser
sim.
Tr minutinhos para cá. Eu vou falar dos
subtipos do Alzheimer, dar uma
introdução ao tema e explicar a partir
do trabalho do Dr. Dale Brads aí, da
equipe dele, como é que ele chegou
nesses seis subtipos. Então, minha
palestra vai ser a respeito disso.
E você, Poliana?
Bom, no simpósio internacional de saúde
integrativa, eh, eu vou falar sobre, eh,
sobre, eh, estudos, eh, científicos, eh,
publicados sobre o protocolo,
né? Então, a minha palestra vai versar
sobre os estudos, mas principalmente
sobre o último estudo que é o estudo
Evanteia,
comentado há pouco no início da live, eh
que eh foi um estudo cujo preprintado
eh agora no final de final de dezembro,
30 de dezembro de 2025, foi
disponibilizado o pré-print, ainda vai
passar pela revisão eh
eh por pares no prer review,
né? para que seja publicado ainda esse
ano, possivelmente a partir de fevereiro
ou março, eh, o estudo já deve tá eh em
definitivo publicado, né? Eh, e que esse
estudo ele traz de resultados assim
arrebatadores,
né? Eh, em relação eh à efetividade do
protocolo COD. Eh, ah, em relação a que
só dando um spoiler, falando um
pouquinho sobre o que que tem de
resultado positivo, né? 100% dos
pacientes eh que se submeteram ao
tratamento com o protocolo Recode
tiveram eh reversão de teclínica
cognitiva. Eh, grande parte deles
tiveram eh eh um desempenho cognitivo ao
final do estudo superior ao que era o
habitual deles antes eh do adoecimento.
Eh, então quando comparado ao ao grupo
B, eh, que fazia o tratamento
tradicional, eh, os pacientes que
subeteram o protocolo Code tiveram eh
uma espécie de evolução eh em que eles
melhoravam em relação, por exemplo, à
memória e os pacientes que não estavam
fazendo protocolo recode, eh, e que
estavam eh basicamente tendo um
tratamento tradicional, eles acabavam
apresentando o declínio eh da memória.
Mas tem uma série de outras eh de outras
habilidades cognitivas eh que foram eh
examinadas e onde se observaram
resultados estarrecedores. E além disso,
eh, o próprio comparativo feito, foi
feita uma análise comparativa
eh, com a eh as drogas mais recentemente
lançadas para o tratamento da doença de
Alzheimer dentro da intervenção
tradicional, que são anticorpos
monoclonais, que é a terapia
antiamiloide. Eh, eh, já tem duas dessas
drogas já aprovadas pela Anvisa no
Brasil, eh que é um tratamento
eh bastante caro, infelizmente, né, mas
que trazia uma promessa de, poxa, agora
parece que temos algo eh que possa
trazer um pouco mais de esperança ali
pros pacientes quando de Alzheimer. E
aí, pelo menos em torno de, ah, será que
tem alguma estabilização em torno de 30%
na evolução da doença? Aí aí quando você
compara a análise comparativa feita
entre o recode eh e os resultados eh
publicados dessas intervenções com esses
anticorpos para a terapia antiamiloide,
que é o tratamento mais moderno, eh, que
se tem dentro da prática tradicional
para doença de Alzheimer, eh o que se
observou é que eh o recode se mostrou
sete vezes o effect size, que é o
tamanho do efeito eh do protocolde eh
nos pacientes com doença de Alzheimer,
ele se mostrou de sete a quatro vezes
maior.
do que o tamanho do efeito eh do
Lecanemab do Donanemab, que são as
drogas da eh da terapia antiamilo
aprovadas no Brasil, né? Eh, e não só no
Brasil, mas aprovada já há há tempos nos
Estados Unidos, em outros locais do
mundo também. Eh, então, eh, esse é um
momento muito importante, eh, para o
protocolo Recode, porque a gente sabe
que
para se fazer pesquisa e para se
publicar os resultados que se tem na
prática clínica, eh, demanda tempo,
demanda pessoas, demanda patrocínio.
Então, muit das vezes, aquilo que você
observa na prática clínica com
tratamento que está começando, lançando
mão da declaração de Rin, que permite ao
médico oferecer ao paciente tratamentos
novos, eh, que possam agregar pro
paciente, né, até que isso esteja
devidamente publicado na literatura,
muit das vezes leva eh anos a fio ou
mais de uma década, né? Eh, então, a
gente tá num momento em que eh muitos
estudos já foram publicados de 2014 para
cá, né, vários estudos foram publicados.
Eh, e agora esse estudo ele traz um peso
eh ele eh eh eh importante eh no sentido
de que eh ele ele demonstra com mais
propriedade ainda do que os estudos
anteriores eh a efetividade do protocolo
recode, né? Então, eh esse vai ser eh, o
tema da minha palestra, porque o assunto
de maior importância que eu entendi que
precisava eh trazer para eh para
apresentar. as pessoas precisam saber eh
que o protocolo Code existe, precisam
saber o que que tá sendo publicado,
porque afinal de contas eh ah não é algo
assim que ah, tem alguém ali que
inventou, que não, é ciência, tá
publicado. Sim.
Em Portugal, Rodrigo, quando a gente foi
a Portugal fazer o congresso lá do Porto
e eu fiz a minha apresentação, eu já
apresentei um, já não era o resultado
final do Orvanteia, mas era o os
primeiros resultados que
foram divulgados, porque teve uma live
na semana passada, se eu não me engano,
que o Dr. Dale Bradsen, ele divulgou a
publicação, pré-print que a Dra. Pulen
tá tá se referindo agora.
e ele também divulgou o link do estudo
que a gente pôde fazer um download. Mas
antes mesmo disso, eu já tinha eh
levantado as informações eh no
clinicaltrials.gov
e eu apresentei no final, não sei se
você lembra, eh no final eu apresentei
alguns achados já iniciais desse vante.
Ah, foi brilhante sua aula. Parabéns.
Gostei bastante.
Obrigado. Esse Vanteia aí é um estudo
realmente revolucionário, que é o
primeiro randomiz control try, ou seja,
o primeiro estudo randomizado
controlado, né? o aleatorizado,
controlado que fala sobre isso, porque
as grandes críticas que tinham, também
mostrei isso na minha aula lá em
Portugal, as grandes críticas que todos
faziam a respeito do protocolo recode é
que não tinha esse tal de random mais
control trial, não tinha um RCT, né? Ah,
não tem ciência, não tem ciência. Muito
bem. O problema é que o paradigma hoje
da ciência,
ainda se baseia muito no cartesianismo,
né? Renê Decart foi um gênio, mas eh
hoje em dia a gente não pode mais basear
a biologia de sistemas em eh na parte
cartesiana, porque eh o que funciona
hoje para doenças complexas e
multifatoriais são múltiplos estudos de
n de um. O que significa isso? Você tem
que comparar a pessoa antes e depois de
uma intervenção. Não adianta mais a
gente fazer esses estudos que a gente
pega 2000, 3.000, 5.000 pessoas e dá o
mesmo remédio para pessoas completamente
diferentes, que tem uma biologia
totalmente diferente, que tem eh
particularidades completamente
diferentes, porque assim, dentro daquele
grupo de 5.000 pessoas, vai ter 10%, vai
ter o subt vai ter 10% do subtipo dois,
20% do subtipo três. E aí aquela
intervenção que vai atuar num dos
subtipos, ele vai pegar só um pedaço
pequeno daqueles 5.000 pessoas e isso
vai dar no final uma estatística fraca.
E aí você vai ficar pensando que aquele
remédio não funciona, quando na verdade
ele é extremamente eficaz para um
subtipo. Então a gente tem que evoluir
esses estudos aí, usar biologia de
sistemas, sistemas complexos, porque de
fato essa maneira tradicional, entre
aspas, que se faz ciência, ela tá
obsoleta para doenças crônicas. e
multifatoriais e complexos, como é o
caso da doença de Alzheimer. Então isso
foi uma coisa que ao estudar o tema me
chamou muita atenção e que de fato a
gente vai ter que usar metabolômica,
todos os estudos ômicos para poder
evoluir com isso, para que a gente possa
eh fazer esses múltiplos estudos de N de
um, começar a comparar a pessoa no
começo, no final do tratamento e não
ficar juntando um grupo super
heterogêneo, um estudo grande, para no
final falar que aquele aquela
intervenção única não é efetiva. Então
eu acho que isso é uma grande evolução
que a gente precisa passar agora no nos
estudos clínicos desse tipo de doença.
Muito bom. Eu eu queria eu queria também
falar que no CIS agora a gente vai ter o
Afons Salgado.
Você comentou sobre a importância da
foto de modulação e o Afonso Salgado é
um professor que já mora em Orlando, é
brasileiro, mas ele estudou em Harva
exatamente alguns protocolos de
fotobiomodontulação
e a gente vai ter os aparelhos dele
participando da nossa feira. Então, se
você quiser conhecer mais sobre essa
nova tecnologia de fotomodulação e como
ela atua na melhora da memória do
rejuvencimento cerebral e também de
doenças eh neurodegenerativas,
vamos lá, 13, 14 e 15 de março desse
ano, tá? E eu queria falar só
rapidamente o que que eu vou tá falando
nessa parte, porque a odontologia ela
também para para que a gente possa est
colaborando para a memória e o
resultado, é muito importante o papel da
odontologia para remover os focos
inflamatórios infecciosos que acabam
que acabam prejudicando.
Melhorou?
É, tá um rol de fundo.
Oi. Bom, então queria, acho que melhorou
agora, né?
Melhorou.
A parte odontológica, ela é muito
importante porque da mesma forma que a
gente tem eh fatores inflamatórios no
intestino que preparam o nosso nosso
corpo para luta e para fuga, preparando
o nosso corpo para uma guerra,
o nosso sistema ele começa a preparar
uma série de defesas. E essas defesas a
longo prazo é que vão prejudicar a nossa
saúde cerebral. Então, quando a gente
tira os focos inflamatórios infecciosos,
tira as toxinas,
a gente também acaba melhorando todo o
processo de micronutrição,
microcirculação, oxigenação e limpeza.
Então, uma coisa rápida, só pra gente
entender, são os problemas periodontais,
que são bactérias que vão se acumulhando
ao redor do dente.
A gente tem também a ce. A gente tem os
canais que muitas vezes não são bem
tratados, não por causa do dentista, mas
porque a diversidade anatômica acaba
dificultando a limpeza completa.
lesões dentro do osso que acabam levando
à necessidade de crescer uma um soldado
nosso que é o CCL5 que acaba
prejudicando também. Fora isso, a gente
tem que o que o amalade dentital, que
ele produz o mercúrio, o mercúrio ele
tem uma afinidade muito grande eh pela
nossa a nossa célula cerebral, assim
como o tiroide, rins, fígado. Então ele
vai nos prejudicar muito. a gente
precisa remover o amalgama dental, a
gente precisa tirar as correntes
galvânicas, precisa pensar que na
comunicação do cérebro com o resto do
corpo existe também uma uma comunicação
elétrica e a gente tem que entender como
ela acontece e tirar essa essa
eh essa interferência de forma que seja
super favorável para o paciente.
Então, tudo isso vai ser falado durante
esse evento e queria convidar mais uma
vez vocês a participarem e também a
queria convidar a conhecerem melhor o
trabalho do Dra. Ana Dúria e Dra.
Poliana Castro que estão aí nas mídias,
né? Depois queria que vocês colocassem,
eh, falassem aqui pro pessoal, para quem
ainda não conhece, para tá seguindo. O
meu é Dr. Rodrigo 25 e eu tô sempre
trazendo uma série de dicas e novidades,
altas tecnologias para que possa também
tá tratando dessa parte. Como a gente tá
chegando no final aqui, eu queria que
vocês deixassem uma mensagem aí para
quem tá nos assistindo e para que a
gente possa encerrar. Antes de mais
nada, queria agradecer aos dois. É uma
pena que o Dr. Tipessa
vez, mas ele vai participar conosco e
trazer mais informações ainda sobre o o
apesar que vocês falaram, né, com tanto
conhecimento, eu eu babo assim. e fico
super orgulhoso e vocês dois de estarem
trazendo o recode pro Brasil e serem
essa grande referência
aqui sul-americana.
Uma vez me indicaram pacientes
sul-americanos, porque acho que eh não
tem ainda dentistas, né? Não sei se tem
ou não, mas eu acredito que também vocês
devam estar recebendo pacientes, né,
sul-americanos do do mundo todo, pela
competência que vocês mostram, pelos
resultados, pelo cuidado, pela
humanidade. Então, só tenho a
parabenizar vocês dois e agradecer.
Agora, como
estamos encerrando, queria ouvir as suas
sua mensagem depois o Dr.
Rodrigo, gostaria muito de agradecer a
você pelo convite de fazer essa live pra
gente falar sobre o BRode. Eh, muito
importante a gente conseguir divulgar eh
sobre o método.
eh a parabenizar você pelo seu trabalho,
porque eh eu vejo muito eh o quanto você
eh o quanto eu recebo de elogios eh dos
tratamentos que você faz nos pacientes
que nós temos em comum, né? Então,
agradecer pelo pelo pelo cuidado, né?
Eh, que você tem. Eh, e a esse esse é um
momento muito eh muito importante. O o o
simpósio integrativo, simpósio
internacional de saúde integrativa é um
evento eh muito importante para auxiliar
na divulgação do RCO. Eh, eu como membro
da Alzheimer Survivors Foundation, eh,
que é uma instituição filantrópica que
se destina a auxiliar na divulgação eh
do protocolo Recode.
Eh, fico muito grata eh a por esse
momento dessa live, pelo simpósio que tá
para acontecer, pelo seu convite eh para
poder palestrar no simpósio, né? Eh,
dentro da fundação, eh, eu faço parte do
Advisor Board, que é o Conselho
Consultivo, eh, aonde, ah, a gente tem o
papel de eh de divulgar a assim, eu
fiquei responsável pela
internacionalização da divulgação
internacional do Record. Eh, então o seu
simpósio tem um papel eh eh
importantíssimo eh paraa divulgação do
Recode no Brasil. Eh, e eu como membro
da Fundação dos Sobreviventes do
Alzheimer, eh, sou muito grata eh a você
pelo seu trabalho eh nessa direção, né?
Eh, e só fazendo parênteses, essa
fundação ela é formada eh não só por
profissionais certificados no método,
mas também por eh pacientes que
sobreviveram à doença, que conseguiram
reverter o declínio cognitivo da doença,
como a Jude Benjamin, que foi a patient
zero, foi a primeira paciente que
reverteu a doença eh em 2012, eh
utilizando o tratamento com Protocolo
Recode. Ela recentemente fez uma
travessia a pé que durou mais de 6
meses. Desde abril de 2025 até 15 de
novembro de 2025. Ela ah começou a
caminhada dela pisando no Oceano
Pacífico em San Diego, em abril, e
atravessou o território americano de
oeste e a leste e terminando a caminhada
dela eh a colocando o pé nas águas do
Atlântico em Santo Augustino, na
Flórida, né? Eu estive presente lá nesse
trecho final da caminhada dela, eh, a
tive a a alegria de conhecê-la, eh, que
é uma pessoa que, conseguiu reverter o
teclínico cognitivo da doença, eh, e,
eh,
o, transformou a experiência que ela
teve com a doença em motivação para
levar essa mensagem a outras pessoas que
precisem, né? Então, eh, os
sobreviventes da doença existem, né?
como é um tratamento novo, é pouco
conhecido. Além dela, eh, Luci Vetsky,
que é outra sobrevivente, estava conosco
na caminhada, faz parte da Fundação dos
Sobreviventes do Alzheimer. Então, eh,
elas e outras pessoas que se
beneficiaram no protocolo recode, eh,
tão, eh, eh, estão trabalhando para que
o protocolo recode seja difundido eh eh
e para que mais pessoas que tenham
indicação, seja pessoas com doenças com
a doença de Alzheimer, com estágios
prédemenciais, como declínico cognitivo
leve, pessoas com outras doenças
degenerativas que acometam a memória, eh
pessoas que tenham qualquer queixa
cognitiva, todas essas pessoas têm
indicação. de tratamento com protocolo
Recode. Então, eh
essa eh em nome da fundação, eu agradeço
eh pelo seu convite, né, tanto paraa
live de hoje quanto para palestrar no
CIS e pelo todo o esforço que você tá
fazendo para que o SIS aconteça e seja
um grande sucesso de divulgação eh do
protocolo. Gratidão. Gratidão a você.
Muito obrigado, viu? Obrigado mesmo,
doutora.
Muito bem, eu queria agradecer a
oportunidade de estar aqui com a Poliana
que nós fizemos após junto, né, e a
gente não se fala muito, né, a gente não
tem muita oportunidade de conversar e
foi muito bom ter essa as informações
que ela me passou. Não sabia que você
tinha participado do final da caminhada.
Eu tava acompanhando pelos e-mails, né,
do do Recode, essa história muito
interessante dessa caminhada pelos
Estados Unidos, né? Eu não sabia que
você tava tão envolvida com isso. Achei
bem interessante.
E realmente vamos trocando ideia, vamos
fazer um evento aí maravilhoso, né,
Rodrigo? Se Deus quiser, Deus não vai
nos abençoar paraa gente poder
eh informar as pessoas da melhor maneira
possível sobre esse protocolo que já
existe há uns 8 anos praticamente e que
muito pouca a gente sabe.
É muito importante essa divulgação e
você tá dando esse espaço e por isso
muito grato, Rodrigo, eh, por isso. Bem,
ficar te elogiando aí seria um pouco
abundante da minha parte, porque a gente
já é praticamente irmão, né?
A gente faz live o tempo todo aí com
muita frequência,
então você já é irmão, então ficar te
elogiando, o pessoal deve tá até
enjoado, né, de ficar escutando e
elogiando o Rodrigo. O Rodrigo é um
parceirão, é um cara de um coração
enorme, maravilhoso,
uma pessoa aí que muita coisa
é um gentleman, como eu costumo dizer.
para ele. E a gente vai fazer inclusive
um evento maravilhoso. Com certeza todos
vocês estão escutando, pessoal, vocês
vão ter acesso livre, tá? A parte
geral ali dos standes. Mesmo então que
vocês não se inscrevam para ver as
palestras, vocês podem ir lá tomar um
café comigo, tomar um café com o Rodrigo
e com a Moriana. E vai ser uma
experiência muito legal de ter vocês lá
para vocês aprenderem sobre eh essas
questões são muito importantes que,
infelizmente a mídia não divulga. A
mídia fica só divulgando drogas
caríssimas com efeitos colaterais
terríveis. Que a gente não tá dizendo
aqui que não tem indicação do Lecanumab,
do aducanumab.
Tem indicação sim, mas eh são drogas que
não atuam na origem do problema. A
origem do problema é multifatorial.
E enquanto
a mídia esconde isso das pessoas, né?
Então o trabalho da Poliana aí com a
fundação é fundamental e não sabia desse
trabalho dela, fiquei sabendo agora. E
se eu puder ajudar, eu vou ajudar nesse
trabalho. E nós vamos conversar mais
sobre isso, né, Poliana? Depois para
entender melhor como é que funciona
isso. E a gente precisa realmente nadar
contra corrente, porque a gente fala tem
umas coisas que não interessa o sistema,
não interessa o establishment. Então a
gente precisa ter muita força, muita
resiliência para poder realmente
divulgar
coisas que muitas vezes não depende de
um medicamento super caro, né, da da Big
Farma, né, não que a gente não tá eh
desvalorizando, dizendo que não
funciona, mas que realmente, como eu
falei, a Dra. Puliana também reforçou o
estudo Evantea tá mostrando que os
resultados são muito superiores quando
você tem uma abordagem multifatorial.
Então, queria agradecer a todos vocês aí
pela presença, pedir desculpa pelos
problemas técnicos. Eu vou comprar o um
microfone pro Rodrigo, certo? Que ele tá
precisando. Vou dar dar de presente para
ele. Tem aqui que tava sem bateria.
Eu também vou, eu descobri também que
talvez eu seja um dos culpados, né? Eu
tava usando um fone sem fio junto com o
microfone. Talvez eu seja um dos
culpados aí da parte técnica não ter
sido perfeita, mas a gente vai trabalhar
para as próximas vezes ser melhor.
Pessoal, eu não tenho como agradecer a
vocês por estarem participando, né?
Vocês sabem que nós viemos com uma
missão para cá que é, eu acredito que a
de vocês é bem parecida com a minha, que
é servir. E isso que vocês estão
possibilitaram hoje aqui é exatamente
isso. Então queria agradecer mais uma
vez esses dois grandes profissionais que
vocês são que me inspiram a mim e a toda
a nossa equipe aqui da da 25
odontologia.
Sou fã dos dois de carteirinha e é por
causa de vocês que eu fiz o programa
Recode e espero que vocês continuem
esperando milhares, milhões de pessoas
aí no caminho de vocês. Que Deus abençoe
muito vocês, a todos que nos assistiram.
Um abraço especial pro Martin Giss, que
é o presidente, né, Poliana, da
associação
e que
é um dos é um dos membros fundadores,
os membros fundadores e a gente tem se
comunicado e eu vou tá participando aí
sexta-feira dessa live aí que vai ter.
Então, muita gratidão a todos, um forte
abraço para todo mundo aí e a gente se
vê lá no SIS. Até mais. Obrigada,
Rodrigo. Um beijo grande. Obrigada.
Fiquem com Deus.
Obrigado. Fique com Deus.
Outro.